CBS News political contributor Duval
Patrick is the former Democratic
governor of Massachusetts and he joins
us now
governor responsible for the well the
analysis has already begun it was
definitely now it's pretty cold stuff
who had a strong performance last night
well I think it was it was really
senator Warren's night in many respects
when she wasn't speaking the other
candidates were speaking about her or
about her well you know she's a she is a
prominent candidate she's got a lot of
ideas and a lot to a lot that she's put
out sort of dip to serve as a target she
would not say whether middle-class taxes
would go up under her plans now why
would she not say that well I I don't
know but my guess is that she's getting
some of the advice that Democrats often
get which is not to let the tax word
pass your lips but I have to tell you I
listened to senator Sanders talk about
paying for Medicare for all in ways that
would include a tax on middle-class
citizens as well as on the rich and I
listened to senator Warren talked about
how costs would go down and they're both
right they're both right the thesis is
that you spread this cost around to
everybody you get a lower cost
alternative to then private insurance
and in that way everybody's costs go
down although you have to put a little
bit in to make that happen and I suspect
that that is true of Senator Warren but
it's enormously frustrating not to have
her to have her not you know be how do
you think the former vice president
handled the questions about his son's
business dealings in Ukraine well I feel
for him in some ways because I think you
know his family's not on the ballot yeah
and when his family any one's family
gets pulled in having to defend their
choices and their behavior is always
hard I've had that experience obviously
on smaller smaller scale I would have
expected his answer to be crisper he's
you know this has been broiling around
for some while now and people some
people were frustrated he hadn't said
more yes yes
well you know look I think I'm a fan of
the vice-president I've known him a long
time I have always felt that his support
was soft and it feels like his campaign
is contracting rather than rather than
expanding do you think he should have
been more forceful on this well I think
look it's I want to be careful I want to
appreciate that being a candidate like
being in office is a blend of substance
and performance art and I don't want to
elevate the performance art you know
it's one of the things we do so I want
to be carry it stuff stand there for
three hours and try to get your that's
the thing you've got 12 candidates on
the on the stage governor and you know
that when your moment comes you got to
make your moment yeah so do you think
anything that anybody said last night
move the needle one way or the other for
anybody I don't I don't but I'm not sure
that's the frustrating I'm not sure
that's the point on because you know
when you say move the needle I think
many folks think that means does it
affect your poll numbers yeah I'm sure
that the poll numbers mean much right
now I keep meeting people who who said
you know it's too much right now I'm not
focused right now I'll focus when there
are fewer candidates and I hope that bit
more and I suspect that moment will come
soon people who are focused you think
the candidates struck the right balance
between attacking each other and
attacking the opposition president Trump
yeah I think it was mostly a night about
ideas and that's good yeah and I think
it did disability that we in the
Democratic Party are a party of ideas
and big ideas that meet the big
challenges in people's lives and that's
important that's an important contrast
between what our party is about and what
the current national Republican Party is
about which is about hoarding benefits
for a few and and the rest of the rest
of the working public very very quickly
do you think Bernie Sanders resolved
questions about his health last night I
don't think they'll go away but he was
certainly vigorous and I'm glad to see
that he did look very strong last night
always good to have you at the table be
with you thank you